door he's got bolts on the inside and
outside all the deck hands are really
worn out here yeah they have very weird
latex outfits for them to wear oh yeah
it's the money that that [ __ ] guy
must have God yeah he's got his own jet
and he has his own like a jet jet he has
a 747 yeah 747 yes and he has a runway
in his house for he has like multiple
planes but why would like yeah look at
that full story behind all tows private
jet fleet look at he's got his arm out
the window seeing you flies are the wind
it's a [ __ ] commercial plane yeah in
the back room is just it's all like a
slip and slide with baby oil look at
that look how many get multiple streams
if you know he flew for Qantas as a
commercial pilot he did yes like on he
actually let him fly he's that good of a
pilot Wow
that I think he has some sort of
commercial standing with Qantas he has a
military jet just in case song calls my
home oh that's really crazy mad at him
asking to get a hand job at a massage
yeah hash tag baller holy [ __ ] yeah that
is ballin that's a crazy yacht man I
mean that's like a hundred million
dollar yacht right there where do you
make those money uh I mean how much
money do you make from like pulp fiction
I hear that ones like that we about
being a Russian spy or T Taylor has his
fort you know like his like well his
wealth wealth wasn't he kind of depleted
when Pulp Fiction those like around 93
yeah and then that made him so famous
and hot again that he was just he was a
twenty million dollar movie guy for four
while that was lasting face-off yeah
he's but he's doing terrible movies now
yeah busy yeah did that gaudy movie
it's supposed to be we should probably
have a fight companion for Gotti I heard
it was really bad I've heard it so bad
I'm
you would do which we should do November
rolls around we can get drunk again yeah
yeah that's good watch that hammered and
watch this gaudy movie it's supposed to
be a wretched sack of [ __ ] let's do it
we'll do that
I was we've been meaning to do that what
was the other terrible movie we're
meaning to do that with roar that movie
about oh that's right
that's right there was a movie where a
guy who is a lion trainer actually made
a movie with lions and a bunch of people
that were making the thing I'll play
that play the clip let's hear the clip
do you have the wrong music plan that
this is this is a scene slash trailer
from god the music is really the sting
song
that's how with piece-of-shit movie this
is that trailer sucks look at this is
like an acting class good let it play
out willed you tube yank us for the
audio look at him there's a look he just
it's so fake
okay kill it must feel like you can't
even do a mobster anymore it's like it
feels like a joke to play you could do
it but it would have to be like you have
to be phantoms gala no Phoenix back to
life like if James Gandolfini was alive
today he's a problem moving yeah sure
cuz you believed it right it's got to be
authentic yeah you'd believe it but he
gotta be well it's it's gotta be done I
mean Scorsese could probably do it again
look it's just there's just a bunch of
people he just looks like a grown up
Danny Zuko Danny and the greasers at IU
what Mandy Birds after The Sopranos came
on the air everybody wanted to be
Italian it was one of those gross
moments in time
yeah where all these Italians were like
empowered and they were all talking like
goombazz and they they they all wanted
to [ __ ] get together and have pasta
yeah like ramped it up they take what's
around you know as a person who's
legitimately Italian it was disgusting
like you [ __ ] Abe's yeah what are you
doing you know yeah yeah yeah they
ramped it up you know yeah and like
Greek people like I'm Italian start
pretending that for sure it was you know
there was a time where there were so
many auditions for so many [ __ ]
movies there was all about all Italians
what is this life on the line it's
another a power line guy by the way we
should this you this is probably worse
for sure what the [ __ ] how about urban
cowboy that's this is the premise of
urban cowboy urban cowboy we worked on
one will have a double feature I thought
that our a night well we'll play Gotti
and we'll play life on the line will
sing well they have people sync it up
this is what we'll do this marked those
two mark those two movies and so we'll
get those on the Netflix and we'll after
solar October's over it will get [ __ ]
hammered we'll bring a five gallon jug
of Tito's in here play two movies and I
love it